let me ask you as a father
does it weigh heavy on you that
people get bullied on social networks
so people get bullied in their private
life
but now because so much of our life is
in the digital world the bullying moves
from the physical world to the digital
world so you're now creating a platform
[Music]
on which bullying happens
and some of that bullying
can lead to
damage to mental health and some of that
bullying can lead to
depression even suicide
there's a way heavy on you that people
have
committed suicide or will commit suicide
based on the bullying that happens on
social media
yeah i mean this is uh there's a set of
harms that we basically track and build
systems to fight against and
bullying and
um you know self-harm
are
you know i mean these are these are some
of the biggest things that we that we
are most focused on
um
for bullying
like you say it's going to be
while this predates the internet then
it's probably impossible to get rid of
all of it um you want to give people
tools to fight it um and you and you
want to fight it yourself
and you also want to make sure that
people have the tools to get help when
they need it so i think this isn't like
a question of you know can you get rid
of all bullying i mean it's like all
right um
i mean
i have two daughters and you know they
they fight and you know
push each other around and stuff too and
the question is just how do you how do
you handle that situation
and um
there's a handful of things that i think
you can you can do um
and we talked a little bit before around
some of the ai tools that you can build
to identify when something harmful is is
happening it's actually it's very hard
in bullying because a lot of bullying is
very context specific it's not like
you're trying to fit a formula of like
you know if if if like looking at the
different harms um you know someone
promoting a terrorist group is like
probably one of the simpler things to
generally find because things promoting
that group are gonna you know look a
certain way or feel a certain way
bullying could just be you know someone
making some subtle comment about
someone's appearance that's
idiosyncratic to them and it could look
at just like humor so similar to one
person exactly destructive to another
human being yeah so with bullying i
think there are
there are certain
things that you can find through ai
systems
um but i think it is increasingly
important to just give people more
agency themselves so we've done things
like making it so people can turn off
comments or you know take a break from
um you know hearing from a specific
person without having to signal at all
that they're going to stop following
them or or or kind of make some some
stand that okay i'm not friends with you
anymore i'm not following you i just
like i just don't want to hear about
this but i also don't want to signal
at all publicly that
or to them that that there's been an
issue
and then you get to
some of the more extreme cases like
you're talking about where someone is
thinking about um self-harm or suicide
and
um in there
we found that that is a place where ai
can can identify a lot as well as people
flagging things you know if people are
um expressing something that is is you
know potentially they're thinking of
hurting themselves those are cues that
you can build systems and you know
hundreds of languages around the world
to be able to identify that and one of
the things that i'm
actually quite proud of is we've we've
built these systems that i think are
clearly leading at this point that not
only identify that but then connect with
local um first responders and have been
able to save i think at this point it's
you know in thousands of cases be able
to get first responders to people um
through these systems who really need
them um because of specific plumbing
that we've done between the ai work and
being able to communicate with with
local first responder organizations
we're rolling that out in more places
around the world and um and i think the
team that that worked on that just did
awesome stuff so
i i think that that's a long way of
saying yeah i mean this is this is a
this is a heavy topic and there's you
want to attack it in a bunch of
different ways um
and and also kind of understand that
some of nature is for people to
to to do this to each other which is
unfortunate but um but you can give
people tools and and build things that
help it's still one hell of a burden
though
a platform that allows people to fall in
love with each other
is also by nature going to be a platform
that allows people to hurt each other
and when you're managing such a platform
it's difficult
and i think you spoke to it but the
psychology of that of being a leader in
that space of creating technology
that's playing in this space like you
mentioned psychology
is really damn difficult
and i mean the burden of that is just
it's just great i just wanted to hear
you speak um
to that point
you